and now Paul George pulling the trigger
and missing a three and even chenza with
a rebound
Warriors had a big win on Saturday we
were in San Francisco Monday as Curry
gets the reverse layoff
[Applause]
another great cut by Curry excellent
dips by Greene at six nothing Warriors
an early time out by Ty Lou
where's Curry he's got four points so
far step on the year averaging right
under 30. and so far for mid-range he's
been outstanding
in the lane
and Plumley stripped it
here's Curry
he was knocked to the ground too
incidental contact they say first three
of the game for Steph all the way close
to half court Kawhi turns his head for
one second and there's Curry chasing the
basketball Plumley and Leonard a little
late fifth of the corner plunley
couldn't
steps got it now three on two
[Applause]
Curry looks fires good Steph Curry put
12 in the first
[Applause]
here's Curry going to the left what a
shot off the window for step he's got
14.
[Applause]
here's Curry
Steph Curry has now eclipsed 10 000
career points
just off threes you can't throw the ball
at people
here's Curry another one got another one
for Steph Curry and now Draymond Green
and Marcus Morris exchange words
again let's see
or a lot of a lot of these tussles start
you know a couple plays before yeah
that's a
that's a foula Morris
so it's the second foul on Marcus Morris
they're going to see when it occurred in
relation to the shot by Curry this is
the start of a five-game road trip for
Golden State the Warriors have lost
eight in a row away from home Steph
Curry trying to change that though his
fifth three and 23rd point
Curry's got Zoo bots on him goes right
by him boy that was child play does his
job here
forces steps inside the arc
Leonard in and out rebound green
here's Curry 25 points for step as he
falls away on the Baseline my goodness
how does he do it Steph Curry Wizardry
again first this ridiculous spin
falling out of bounds over Paul George
Gordon way off on the triple try Here
Comes Curry again we
has momentum going what's going to be
next that's just a simple drive an easy
lay of forcing a footprint timeout Curry
now with 29 Points and then the blow-by
by Kawhi
16 points and six assists for George he
averages five assists on the year Curry
for three
two that's his sixth triple of the game
so this first three zubach is just a
little bit late in that coverage tonight
through multiple Defenders for the
Finish
Curry another one sorcery my goodness
Curry to shoot that three and then I
don't know here if he thought Eric
Gordon would keep coming in a soft Blitz
but
I mean are we going to see like we have
now in the NFL as Curry again with your
magic getting past the tune for the
lay-in second personal and so on this
last play zoobots is up but that's the
problem with bringing him up now you're
susceptible to the split Steph knifes
through the fake pass
Curry's got 17 here in the third quarter
37 for the game leaning in oh my God
timely three-point shots but here again
this one he comes off he was old for two
in the first half
Curry
leans in puts it up as he falling face
first and he makes the shot off the
window man with half a second left of
Eric Gordon's performance in the third
quarter but how do you stop this you
can't stop it they did everything
possible before that but he just putting
on an absolute Clinic knocking down
shots and Lambs right now that's his
third 30-point game in his last four
here's Curry got rid of man and splash
it through another three 45 for curry
there's curry in the open floor
goes behind the back step back three
hand in his face it doesn't matter
Steph Curry from Deep elite shot making
and then their Steph Curry shot making
just some ridiculous
Curry nice pass two guys pulls up 50 for
curry matching his season high and
keeping the Warriors alive wouldn't win
this game I think it would just put the
Warriors in a better chance to commit
Steph has 50 points and even when he hit
the 50-point mark they were down by
eight
[Music]